Morgen Linus.
Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hast du äh heute auch schon eine Gravitationswelle detektiert?
Ich merke, dass die Raumzeit auf jeden Fall sehr stark am Wackeln ist hier wieder.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die hundertzweiundsiebzigste Ausgabe eures wöchentlichen Urknalls. Hier werden die
Massen des Universums. Verdichtet und äh ja, wir beobachten alles, was hier äh umeinander rotiert und vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Gravitationswelle abwirft.
Eine spannende Woche, oder? Fandst du dich auch? Ich weiß nicht, ob du das überhaupt so verfolgt hast, so, ich bin ja.
Gravitationswellen? Ich äh ganz normal mit Gravitationswelle messen. Was sollen wir machen?
Musste man ja überhaupt erstmal machen. Ne, das äh die haben die haben das gemacht.
Ja, finde ich gut, also aber das war, wussten wir ja vorher schon. Hat der Einzel dann doch gesagt.
Hat nur gesagt, müsste es geben. Man hat sich zwar mittlerweile daran gewöhnt, dass er immer Recht hat, aber es muss ja dann auch erstmal äh soweit sein, ne?
Naseweise wollen dann wieder irgendwie das nochmal prüfen, was der Mann gesagt hat und.
Tja.
Haben sie gemacht. Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, was die jetzt mit den mit den Gravitationswellen machen.
Die messen so.
Lassen aber jetzt hat man einfach neuen Kanal aufgemacht und da geht was.
Hm. Ja, Weltraum kann man gucken und also die die Raumzeit ist ja unbegrenzt.
Ja?
Unbegrenzt, Hasser unbegrenzte Daten.
Wenn er unbegrenzte Daten hast, dann sind die unbegrenzt. Hat äh das Landgericht Potsdam entschieden.
Da wurde ein Fall verhandelt, wo ein äh Kunde äh.
Ein Mobilfunkvertrag oder Mobilfunkprodukt hatte mit der, mit der, das angepriesen wurde, als Datenvolumen unbegrenzt. Ja, das sein Mobilfunkvertrag äh biete ihm unbegrenztes Datenvolumen.
Und äh das war super, weil er hatte fünfhundert MB mit einundzwanzig Komma sechs Mbit.
Und jetzt funktioniert die Taste und dann nach den nach den fünfhundert MB gehen das runter auf sechsundfünfzig Kilobit. Das ist so zurück in die so zwanzig Jahre zurück zu John Perry Balus.
Anfang des Jahres.
Apple, an dem wir die, an dem wir den Cyber Sales äh independentiert hat. Ähm.
Mhm. Ähm.
Das ist eine Verlangsamverlangsamung, um Faktor,
fünfhundert? Oder würde man würde man in dem Fall sagen, Quotient, fünfhundert? Na ja, fünfhundert Mal langsamer.
Ich finde, zwanzig Jahre zurückgeworfen, finde ich irgendwie noch plastischer, weil das trifft's irgendwie auch ganz gut.
Und der wandelt man wurde also zwanzig Jahre zurückgeworfen in die Weiten des des Cyberspace und ungefähr so viel konnte man dann nämlich auch noch runterladen, wie es damals schon nicht gab,
und dann haben.
Wurde von dem Urteil des ähm die Richter des Landgerichts Potsdam gesagt, das geht, nee so nicht. Weil das eine Reduzierung der Leistung auf nahe null ist mit sechsundfünfzig Kilobit kann man gar nichts mehr anfangen,
Das heißt, ihr dürft nicht mit unbegrenztem Datenvolumen werben. In diesem Falle. Und,
Außerdem hatte dieser Vertrag eine Klause, die ich auch sehr witzig fand, die die Klause dieses Mobilfunkvertrages war ähm.
Dass der Mobilfunkanbieter bei Bedenken gegen die Bonität der Kunden.
Den Vertrag in einer geänderten Form annehmen könnte,
Also so was wie wenn wir Bedenken haben, dass sie sich das gar nicht leisten können, dann nehmen wir ihren Vertrag an, ändern aber die Bedingungen.
Also es gilt dann was anderes als das, was sie unterschrieben haben. Ja super.
Anderes überlegt. So, dass die die Klausel wurde natürlich auch kassiert.
Dieses Urteil, okay, ein Landgerichtsurteil in Potsdam und ähm was es eben bedeutet, ist was es jetzt,
Das Resultat dieses Urteils kann ja jetzt einmal sagen, sein, dass man okay, nicht mehr unbegrenzte Daten anpreist,
oder dass man eben nicht mehr so stark drosselt am Ende der unbegrenzten Daten. Das wären also die beiden Möglichkeiten darauf zu reagieren.
Und das Urteil ist aber noch nicht rechtskräftig und ist eben Landgericht und da kannste von ausgehen, dass der betroffene Provider das natürlich ähm ein bisschen.
Ähm.
Wahrscheinlich durch die durch die Gerichte prügeln werden, weil sie natürlich mit unbegrenztes Volumen unbegrenzt ist immer ein schönes äh Werbewort.
Hast du irgendeine Ahnung, welchen Provider es sich hier ah ja eh plus? Ja. Sehe ich gerade. Mhm.
Ja. Ja aber bei I Plus hast du ja sowieso nicht viel.
Tarif ich finde ja, sie hätten auch noch für den Namen des Tarifs im Prinzip auch nochmal abgemahnt werden sollen.
Das ist sich kein Tarif. Das ist ein Witz. Das kann doch kein Mensch bestellen.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, haben sie einfach auf den Geist äh auf den Sack bekommen. So, jetzt wird man sehen.
Welche Folgen das haben wird, aber es ist betrifft, wahrscheinlich also was jetzt nicht passieren wird, ist, dass wir auf einmal alle keine begrenzten äh alle Beschränkungen bei unseren Datenvolumen auf einmal verlieren, das wird nicht der Fall sein. Ähm aber da,
zumindest ein verbraucherfreundliches Urteil und es werden, ich gehe davon aus, dass etwas passieren wird.
Das jetzt gerichtlich festgestellt wird, um wie viel man drosseln kann, wenn man unbegrenztes Leistung und unbegrenztes Datenvolumen anpreist oder nicht. Bin mal gespannt.
Plus meinte er, sie würden ja auch schon seit längerem nicht mehr mit unbegrenzten Datenvolumen werben, was wohl bei diesem bei diesem Kunden nicht unbedingt jetzt galt, weil zum ersten Mal davon äh damit geworben wurde. Ähm,
Ich finde jetzt allerdings in den Berichten, ich habe jetzt das Urteil nicht gelesen, keine Aussage dazu,
wann sie denn der Meinung sind, dass diese Unangemessenheit nicht mehr vorliegt, also wenn Faktor fünfhundert sozusagen nicht akzeptabel ist, ist die Frage, was ist denn dann akzeptabel? Also wo, ab wo geht's denn los?
Meine meine Interpretation wäre das, also erstens liegt die Begründung, glaube ich, noch nicht vor und wenn also genau diese Frage wären jetzt wären die Provider natürlich jetzt anstrebend zu klären. Weil sie irgendwas wollen sie ja machen.
Ne
Ja, aber das ist äh schön, weil das ist ja nun wirklich eine Sache, die wir auch schon
lange beklagen, also im Prinzip seitdem dieser ganze Flatwahnsinn überhaupt losging, weil das war ja sozusagen noch nie so
Flatrates sind in den aller seltensten Fällen wirklich äh Flatrates und ja, das ist halt so der schleichende Drosseltod
vor allem das muss sich ja jetzt auch nicht nur auf Mobilfunknetze auswirken, sondern gibt ja mittlerweile
auch im selben Hause O2 hat ja im Prinzip dieselbe Drossel äh Taktik auch bei DSL, ne, so nach bestimmtem Volumen schalten wir das mal runter und was ist denn sozusagen dann eine angemessene äh Geschwindigkeit?
Ja, da kommt jetzt ein da kommt jetzt Musik rein in dieses Thema. Ich fürchte ähm ich fürchte, dass das am Ende nur ein paar Werbebegriffe betreffen wird und ähm eher nicht.
Du meinst, wenn man's einfach anders bezeichnet, dann darf man das schon machen. Man darf's dann bloß nicht mehr unbegrenzt nennen.
Prinzipiell kannst du ja anbieten, was du möchtest. Kannst auch sagen, Internet nur an den geraden Tagen des Monats oder so. Kannst du machen.
Kannst du machen? Ja, kann man machen, ne? Auf jeden Fall ist es unlauter und ähm ich muss auch sagen,
Ich verstehe diese auch nicht,
Also jetzt mal so rein aus aus Marketing Gesichtspunkten. Nicht, dass ich mich da als Experte äh zeigen möchte, aber.
Dieses schlecht umgehen mit den Gründen.
Also ich meine, wie kommt man überhaupt auf so eine Idee, so eine Begrenzung zu machen? Es ist ja auch häufig auch so bei sechsundfünfzig Kilobit, kann man.
Kann man, weiß ich gar nicht,
sehr, sehr schwierig da überhaupt noch in heutigen Zeiten von Geschwindigkeit zu sprechen, aber äh in meinem O2-Vertrag war das ja teilweise so, dass man auf,
so GPRS Speed runtergeht, also so bis auf neun sechs. Und das Absurde ist, dass ihr dann von einem erwarten, um das wieder freizuschalten, dass man irgendwelche auf irgendwelchen Seiten klickt,
Ich hätte jetzt gern mehr,
aber die Datenrate ja noch nicht mal mehr ausreicht, um diese Seiten zuverlässig zu laden, um das durchzuführen, dann haben sie das irgendwann so auf SMS umgestellt, damit so ein bisschen geht. Aber das ist, das zeigt einfach auch diese ganze Absurdität.
Ich kenne jetzt irgendwie so Tarife von Eplus, da äh wenn du da über dein Volumen gehst, dann sagen buchen sie das automatisch dazu
okay, du hast dein Volumen aufgebaut. Hier kriegst du jetzt irgendwie fünfhundert MB dazu zum Preis von fünf Euro. Und wenn dir das drei Monate in Folge passiert, dann gehst du in die nächsthöhere Tarifkategorie. Was ja eigentlich ein.
Das ist ja im Prinzip ein Service an für dich, weil wenn du die die gehen machen sie ja quasi, dadurch wird's auch wieder billiger. Ne, also irgendwie so
du hast fünfhundert MB, brauchst jeden Monat aber sechshundert, ne, dann zahlst du eben drei Monate lang irgendwie fünf Euro drauf für nochmal fünfhundert MB und irgendwann kommst du in den nächsthöheren Tarif dauerhaft, der aber nur was weiß ich,
zwei Euro mehr kostet. Also ich habe hier die Zahlen jetzt grob äh zusammengewürfelt,
Irgendwas müssen die machen, um eben um irgendwie in ihren Produkten zu differenzieren und äh ist natürlich erstaunlich, wenn das billigste Produkt dir schon irgendwie unbegrenztes Datenvolumen gibt,
Ich verstehe auch diese Konzepte nicht so wirklich, diese also gut, woraus, woraus.
Wie wird heute ein Mobilfunkvertrag definiert? Eigentlich dass man 'ne Festnetz und 'ne Mobilfunk-Flat hat, davon geht man aus,
Und dann gibt's halt noch irgendwie gibt's Daten und da sagt man wie viel, zwei, drei, vier Daten hat man locker.
Ja, ich finde alle Datentarife, die in Deutschland angeboten werden, finde ich hanebüchen und schlecht.
Ja, sollen wir jetzt jeden einzelnen nochmal durchsprechen oder zum nächsten Thema gehen?
Nee, ich wollte einfach nur noch meine meiner.
Ich wollte das gekonnt umschiffen, weil ich weiß, dass das das was ist, wo du dich fest frisst. Fest beißt. Finde ich auch nicht gut.
Ich sage nur, finde ich nicht gut. Finde ich auch nicht. Ja, wir finden das mal äh nicht super.
Aber weißt du, was wir super finden? Die indische Regulierungsbehörde.
Ja, die ist geil.
Ähm.
Fans auf, wir liken das.
Wir liken.
Die verbietet,
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das schon oder wir haben darüber immer mal kurz gesprochen am Rande, dass in Indien natürlich diese diese Netzneutralitätsgeschichte ein eine sehr große ist. Indien ist ein Land mit irgendwie eins Komma drei Milliarden Einwohnern
Markt, da kann man noch Geld verdienen. Viele von diesen Menschen ähm,
nach westlichen äh nach westlichen Standards enorm arm,
die haben die meisten Menschen haben da schon Mobiltelefone, aber so dieses ganze mobile Internet oder so äh ist da noch relativ neu, ja? In der für die Breite der Bevölkerung. Natürlich gibt's eine eine,
eine schmale Mittelklasse, äh die fast irgendwie europäische.
Jetzt sind wir mit Europa vergleichbar ist. Die rennen natürlich auch alle mit iPhones rum oder so, ne, aber da ist noch richtig viel zu digitalisieren in diesem Land.
Und,
Hast du auch relativ große äh relativ viele Mobilfunkprovider da rumrennen und viele viele Player an diesem Markt und ähm.
Die Unternehmen blicken natürlich auf Indien. Ähm weil Indien.
Auch gerne Dinge selber gemacht hat,
Ja, also die, die, es ist nicht unbedingt sicher, dass Indien, wenn wenn die jetzt alle Internet kriegen, dann auch als allererstes auf Facebook gehen. Ja, Indien hat schon immer auch darauf geachtet, dass in seinem, in diesem Land,
Produkte von in dann auch hergestellt werden, ja? Und ähm,
Hat sich im dieses dieses Produkt Produkt Free Basics,
von der von der von der Non Government Organisation Internet dot org, hinter der sich eben Facebook verbirgt.
Gibt eben,
kostenlosen Zugang zu Facebook übers Internet und zu einigen Bildungs-, Gesundheits- und Job an Diensten. Ja, also irgendwie,
basic, basale Internetangebote kosten nichts, das heißt äh Leute kriegen das im Prinzip einfach freigeschaltet. Dein Handy kann auf einmal Daten empfangen,
und dann kannst du damit,
bestimmte Seiten kostenlos aufrufen und wenn du dann eben, und das funktioniert sogar auch, wenn du jetzt gar keinen Datentarif hast, ja? Nur wenn du keinen Datentarif hast, dann äh hast du natürlich in der Regel auch keinen datenfähiges Telefon.
Das ist ein kleines Argument, was der Zuckerberg immer vergisst,
und damit wollen sie natürlich auch an dem Punkt, dass dass ihr Facebook eben gegenüber anderen Angeboten bevorteilt ist und wollen sich diesen Markt erschließen.
Und die drei hat also jetzt gesagt, alle Telkos, allen Telkos wird es verboten,
Ausnahmeregelungen für Einzelangebote zu schaffen. Und das klingt in meinen Ohren nach einer sehr strengen, klaren Netznetraletralitätsverordnung. Keine.
Keine Ausnahmen in irgendeiner Form für irgendwelche Einzelangebote. Fertig. Kannst gerne äh äh Videostreaming bevorteilen und und Audio-Streaming nicht oder so. Das ist aber dann für alle Anbieter gleich, aber äh nicht für einzelne Angebote.
Und zuvor gab es massive Werbekampagnen, also Facebook hat da richtig reingeworfen, richtig Geld reingeworfen, ähm um auch sein Wachstum zu halten. Bald haben die ja einfach mal den den Westen haben sie jetzt erschlossen
Ja? Und wenn sie jetzt neue, neue Leute brauchen, die in Facebook äh die Logbuch Netzpolitik liken, dann äh müssen sie sich die eben in Indien holen.
Und das ist eben jetzt schief gegangen. Da hat der Zuckerberg einen ähm einen Blogbeitrag geschrieben bei der Times of India und argumentierte da ganz interessant. Er sagte Bibliotheken haben auch nicht jedes Buch,
Aber sie sind eine Welt des Guten. Öffentliche Krankenhäuser bieten nicht jede Behandlung, aber sie retten Leben.
Und so soll eben Free Basics den Digital Devide abbauen. Und benennt dann irgendwie das Beispiel eines Farmers äh Garnesh, der irgendwie durch Free-Basics,
irgendwie Wetterbericht gucken konnte und dann seine Produktivität,
also er wusste vorher, wann der Monsun kommt, das weiß jeder Inder sowieso, wann der kommt, alles,
Äh aber der genau, der hat also aus dem Internet gesehen, wann der Monsun kommt und konnte dann irgendwie besser und jetzt ist er ein, ne, er hatte, lebt ja jetzt den amerikanischen Traum wegen Free Basics,
Und er sagte,
Also argumentiert eben über diesen Digital Devide und berühmt sich, dass es bisher fünfunddreißig Operators gibt äh auf der Welt, die insgesamt fünfzehn Millionen Personen mit mittels free Basics, mit dem Netz verbinden.
Und fünfzig Prozent dieser Person würden innerhalb von dreißig Tagen dann volles Netz dazu buchen. Ähm aber er behauptet.
Oder er sagt dann, wenn wir dieses free Basic jetzt den Leuten nicht geben, dann lassen wir eine Milliarde Menschen in Indien zurück,
Ja, also diese Zahl stimmt ja nicht, weil angeblich ja die Hälfte von dieser Milliarde sowieso schon dann irgendwie sich richtiges Internet kaufen würde oder so, keine Ahnung. Und Free Basics würde die Netzneutralität nicht ähm verletzen. Eine,
eine ein Beleg für dieses für diese Äußerung findet er allerdings nicht.
Und ähm wirbt aber dann oder preist die Free Basics an, dass sie darin ja noch nicht mal Werbung hätten auf der free Variante von Facebook,
ja, macht aber auch Sinn, wo wollen die auch hinlinken? Wenn du da weißt du.
Ich freue mich sowieso gerade, wenn er meint, so der Herr, bei Bibliotheken sind ja sozusagen auch nicht alle Bücher, ja, heißt das, dass dann dann könnte er, dass Facebook ja auch so machen, dass einfach nur so jede dritte oder vierte Seite auf Facebook dann auch wirklich sich klicken lässt.
Macht er doch!
Nicht die Werbung, sondern sozusagen die Profile und so weiter. Ja, ähm oder das halt auch, sagen wir mal, nur auf fünfundzwanzig Prozent dieser überhaupt Facebook,
zu haben ist, muss man wahlweise mal Google Plus, ne, dann verfügbar ist, aber halt Facebook nicht oder Twitter.
Twitter ist ja eh immer mal wieder nicht verfügbar.
Na ja.
Schön war.
Aber es ist, ist wirklich hanebüchen, ne? Und vor allem, er müsse, er müsse es wirklich besser wissen. Und äh nein, er weiß es auch besser. Und, und, und das, das macht es so unlauter sein
Vorstoß. Wenn er halt jetzt mal sagen würde, hier Leute, ich bin scheiße reich und äh äh jeder äh jede Verbreiterung des Internets, äh jede Erweiterung des Internetzugangs, ist auch gut für mich. Und ich schmeiße jetzt hier einfach mal ein paar von meinen Milliarden ab oder,
ich mache hier einfach einen kostenlosen Internetzugang. Fertig! Ja?
Machen ja andere auch.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja okay.
Nach nach europäischem Maßstab alles kostenlos, also da,
da ist nicht viel, da ist eben leider auch mit dieser mit dieser Milliarde Menschen auch nicht nicht sage ich mal nach europäischem Maßstab Geld zu verdienen, ne.
Die ist eben, ist eine andere sind andere Reichtumsverhältnisse in Indien,
Na ja, aber schön war dann eigentlich, also Zuckerberg mit einer mit einer etwas coolen Argumentation äh in der Times of India. Und dann geht Mark an Dresden hin,
oder Mark Andreasen, keine Ahnung. Andresen, ich weiß es nicht. Der Mann äh sitzt im ähm,
im Aufschluss im im Aufsichtsrat von Facebook, meine Güte,
Ja, ein bisschen schwierig. Und er sagt dann zu diesem Thema, Anti-Kolonie ist,
Anti-Kolonialismus war für das indische Volk über Jahrzehnte wirtschaftlich katastrophal. Warum jetzt also damit aufhören, hat er getwittert? Also er.
Antikkolonialismus war für sie katastrophal.
Ja, warum also warum jetzt also damit aufhören?
Also er sei Ebbe, er sagt, im Prinzip, dass diese Entscheidung eine Antikkolonialistische wäre und das Anti-Kolonialismus Indien geschadet hat.
Und die sich doch besser vom weißen Mann, dass Facebook jetzt mit dem.
Bitte. Geil.
Da hat er dann aber auch selbst von dem Zuckerberg einen für aufn Sack bekommen für den Spruch.
Das ist ja ein Wichser. Das ist ja krass. Also wer nicht weiß, wer mag Andresen ist, der Typ hat ja mal den Netzgapegata äh uns gebracht so, also er hat durchaus seinen ähm,
seinen Beitrag geleistet zur äh Ausdehnung des äh Netzes oder speziell in dem Fall natürlich des Webs.
Ist allerdings auch seit einiger Zeit wirklich nur noch im Wesentlichen als Investor und äh so weiter äh unterwegs. Und ich habe langsam so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass.
Manchmal zu einem gewissen Realitätsverlust. Meine Realität ist immer sehr äh äh relativ,
In diesem Fall zeigt sich das auf jeden Fall recht deutlich. Was ich ja,
haben wir noch einen Aspekt, hast du noch einen Aspekt, den du hier noch beleuchten möchtest? Äh ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen, dass wir äh letztes Jahr im April,
schon mal darauf hingewiesen haben, dass ähm aus der Nutzerszene heraus, auf YouTube vor allem, sich ja so einen Widerstand gegen diese ganzen äh Tendenzen überhaupt erstmal rumge.
Die hatten wir, glaube ich, auch damals verlinkt, diese.
Verlinkt, genau, äh Lokbuch äh hundertneununddreißig, Staatstrojaner Asse Service und ähm da gab's dieses schöne Video von all India Bachot,
keine Ahnung, was das heißt, aber irgendwie Internet auf jeden Fall war ein
sehr populäres Video, das hat hier irgendwie dreieinhalb Millionen Klicks und das hat dann schon was bewirkt, ne? Also das das war schon sehr interessant,
sehen, wie äh da im Prinzip das erste Mal so äh ja in den so ein bisschen seinen Akte-Moment hatte, ne.
Supermoment hat es.
Ich bin, ich bin, ehrlich gesagt, ja, gut, dass die amerikanische Perspektive, die europäische wäre acta. Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du das einschätzt, du hast ja auch ein bisschen mehr Einblick so in äh in die indischen äh Realitäten als ich. Ähm mich überrascht das,
dass es zu so einer Entscheidung äh gekommen ist, dass sozusagen äh die, ich meine, das kriegen wir noch nicht mal in Europa hin.
Ja ähm wie die jetzt zu dieser Entscheidung gekommen sind, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht also,
nachgedacht, ja. Ähm vielleicht also nur der Vollständigkeit halber sollten wir natürlich sagen, warum feiern wir jetzt im Prinzip das, ne, einer Milliarde potenziell einer Milliarde äh indischer Bürger kein kostenloser Internetzugang gegeben wird, weil
dass eben kein Internetzugang war, sondern ein ein World Garden, wo man halt die.
Facebook-Zugang.
Ausgewählten Dienste und Facebook bekommt, damit man möglichst in diesen bleibt. Und das ist ja auch letztendlich,
sage ich mal, das das ultimative Ziel von Facebook, dass,
Internet nur noch dafür da ist, dass Leute sich mit Facebook verbinden.
Das, was Facebook macht, die möchten im Prinzip so gut wie jede sinnvolle soziale Dienstleistung,
in sich selber abbilden und die Menschen möglichst von anderen Dingen fernhalten. Ja, also, ne? Die möchten das, was früher freies Internet war, soll sich einfach eines Tages zentral in Facebook abbilden.
So könnte man das das Streben oder die Strategie Facebook was weiß ich für die
für die Zukunft einfach immer einfach zusammenfassen. Und das ist da, ist das natürlich mit diesen Free Basics genau ein Schritt hin. Und ähm das würde dann eben dazu führen, dass der größere Teil der Ressourcen
die das Internet so bereit hält eben für diesen Menschen nicht mehr zur Verfügung steht und in einer wenn das
wenn der Plan aufgeht eben die Menschen diese auch nicht mehr nutzen würden oder diese auch nicht mehr brauchen würden und sich ein ganzer Markt darauf ausrichten würde,
dass eben Free Basics herrscht,
Wenn du in Indien die Leute erreichen möchtest, ja, siebzig Prozent äh haben nur dann musst du eben eine Facebook-Seite machen. Deswegen habe ich ja jetzt auch eine gemacht für Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Gott.
Ich kriege die jetzt in jeder Sendung und.
Mann.
Genau und.
Geile, die sieht auch so geil aus.
Einer solchen, einer solchen äh Marktexpansionsstrategie ist eben entgegenzutreten. Und ich finde das spannend, dass äh dass die Regulierungsbehörde das jetzt da getan hat.
So. Weitere gute Nachrichten.
Ja, gute Nachrichten. Safe Haber ist ja vorbei.
Gibt gute Nachrichten.
Es gibt gute,
Also Save Harber ist ja vorbei, haben wir ja auch besprochen, das Ding ist irgendwie ausgelaufen. Sie haben dann so im letzten Moment noch gesagt, ja, wir haben jetzt eine Einigung, wir haben auch schon ein Logo dafür und das ist jetzt EU-Privacy Shield, hast du nicht gesehen. Die Details sind noch unklar. Wir hauen noch keinen keinen äh keinen,
Tropfen Tinte auf dem Papier, aber alles wird gut, machen sie bitte keine Sorgen.
Bitte weitergeben.
Und jetzt, wie, wie leben wir in einer Post, Safehaber World? Das ist eigentlich ganz interessant. Dropbox hat jetzt gesagt, sie werden ähm anbieten, die Daten nach Deutschland zu holen. Das wird Deutschland Hosting gibt,
Also wahrscheinlich eine Reaktion auf diese einerseits so eine Geschichte, andererseits auf dieses German Datenschutz und so weiter,
ähm das gibt's allerdings nur für Unternehmenskunden, nicht für Privatkunden. Und.
Funktioniert. Dropbox unterhält keine eigenen Daten,
Sondern funktioniert auf Basis von Amazon, S3. Wofür stehen die drei? Nummer simple, Storage, Solution wahrscheinlich oder sowas. Das heißt, Amazon hat Datenzentren, auf denen kann man Daten runterwerfen und wenn man,
Dropbox nutzt, dann landen die Daten eben auf Dropbox Servern äh auf auf Amazon Speicherservern.
Und äh der Dienst äh verwaltet diese
und äh Amazon bietet seit zwanzig vierzehn die Option, Daten gezielt in Frankfurt abzulegen und Dropbox wird wohl davon dann äh Gebrauch machen.
Das heißt, dieses Ende von Seve Haber hat jetzt zumindest mal einen relativ großen Cloud-Anbieter der USA dazu bewegt, von einem Dienst, von einem Service Gebrauch zu machen, der ihnen jetzt nicht viel Arbeit kostet, aber immerhin, diese Daten kommen dann nach Deutschland
sind eben und dann ist auch ganz klar, dass sie eben einem deutschen äh Gesetz da unter äh unterliegen.
Gleichzeitig rügt die französische Datenschutzaufsicht,
äh CNI Knil äh Facebook ähm,
Für mehrere, für mehrere Datenschutzvergehen und sagen, ihr dürft ohne,
oder ohne einen Safehaber-Regelung dürft ihr keine Daten hier einfach in den USA abpumpen. Ähm und es gibt noch weitere Probleme, die sie in Ankreiden und sagen, ihr habt jetzt drei Monate, um diese Missstände zu beseitigen, sonst berufen wir in Komitee und dann wird hier über Sanktionen entschieden.
Und Facebook betont,
betont in der Reaktion darauf, also Facebook wird sich jetzt irgendwie äh dazu äußern, wird natürlich irgendwie dagegen vorgehen. Aber Facebook sagt immer, die Grundlage für die Datenübermittlung sei nicht die Safehaber-Vereinbarung.
Sondern andere Regelungen, äh die der EU-Datenschutzverordnung irgendeiner Form entsprechen. Und,
Damit widerspricht Facebook aber seine eigenen Datenrichtlinie, die die Nutzer immer äh abklicken müssen. Denn darin steht wörtlich, Facebook
hält sich an die vom US-Handelsministerium veröffentlichten Safehaberbestimmungen für den Datenverkehr zwischen den USA und der EU beziehungsweise den USA und der Schweiz bezüglich der Sammlung, Nutzung und Einbehaltung von Informationen aus der Europäischen Union.
Unsere Zertifizierung kannst du auf der Seite einsehen.
Grandios.
So, die kennen die kennen ihre eigenen AGBs auch nicht.
Haben das Memo nicht gelesen.
Aber ich fand das nur ganz interessant, jetzt so zu sehen, dass da überall so kleine Safehaber-Debatten oder Safehaber ausgelöste Debatten jetzt ähm geführt werden.
Echt so? Rechtsum. Gut, aber das reicht jetzt aber auch erstmal mit den guten Nachrichten, oder?
Ja, jetzt kommen wir mal zu den zu den schlechteren. Ähm wir haben ja bitte?
Hat gegrinst. Bitte? Ich habe schon die ganze Zeit gegrinst.
Wir haben ja ein, wir haben ja ein ähm Deutschland SeeYou. Kennst du den Deutschland Seew?
Nee, echt? Wie für, für Deutschland selber so? Ja. Echt?
Ja. Ja, das ist der Klaus Witt. Ja, er ist der Deutschlands.
Oder fit.
Weiß ich nicht genau, wie fit, fit, fit, fit.
Mit V. Vogel V.
Der hat am äh hat am Montag ein Digital Society Institut an der European School of Management in Technology in Berlin eröffnet. Sowas machen dann Seal Seos?
Und äh hat dann da eine Rede gehalten und sagte, ja also beim.
Würde momentan wäre es ja so, dass bisherige Konzepte zur Cyber-Abwehr mit Firewalls und Früherkennungssystemen nicht mehr ausreichen würden.
Also du wärst den Cyber, ab der Cyber kommt auf dein Unternehmen zu und prallt an Firewall und Früherkennungssystem ab. Das reicht aber nicht mehr aus.
Was man jetzt braucht, sind Echtzeitdaten zur automatisierten Abwehr. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was er damit meint.
Automatisierten Abwehr. Ah ja, Echtzeitdaten worüber? Wovon? Cyber. Über den Cyber. Cyber, Echtzeit, Cyber, Echtzeit Cyberdaten.
Über den Cyber. Echtzetter. Zabadaten braucht man zur automatisierten Abwehr.
Ah. Echtzeiter da.
Ja und mir ist nicht so ganz klar, was er damit jetzt ernsthaft meint, aber er möchte, dass die Anbieter diese Echtzeitdaten zur automatisierten Cyber-Abwehr speichern.
Äh sammeln und auf Inhalte prüfen, die nicht reingehören.
Warte mal, welcher Anbieter wovon?
Das ist also.
Ich glaube, er redet so von Hosting, Anbietern oder so, mir ist nicht ganz klar, was er meint, aber worauf er eigentlich hinaus möchte, ist die schon im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz in den Entwürfen
vorhandene Speicherpflicht für Anbieter von Telekommunikationsdiensten und Zugangsprovider.
Es gibt Speicherfristen für Telekommunikationsdienste und Zugangsprovider. Es gibt aber keine Speicherpflichten für Serverbetreiber. Diese sollte im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz kommen.
Das war das, was wir damals als kleine Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch die Hintertür kritisiert haben. Und was dann auch ähm nach einem
Widerstand der SPD auch aus dem Regierungsentwurf rausgeschnitten wurde. Das heißt, diese
das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz hatte dann nicht diesen Paragraphen, wo gesagt wurde, okay, äh Telemediendienstanbieter müssen Daten speichern, dürfen Daten speichern für die verschiedenen Zwecke?
Ja? Und,
Scheint jetzt, genau das wieder haben zu wollen. Er hat noch keine Gesetzesinitiative, aber er hat seine Bestrebungen angekündigt, dass er genau das haben möchte. Die technische Argumentation dafür ist mir ähm,
erschließt sich mir nicht, aber er will es haben.
Ja, wird ja auch häufiger mal was ähm gefordert, was einem sich nicht unbedingt so erschließt.
Echtzeitdaten zu automatisierten Abwehr. Ich weiß nicht genau, was der meint. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob er es selber weiß,
Naja, dann hat er sich noch irgendwie über Datenschutz und äh Schutz von Daten äh geäußert. Ähm,
Also dass der Daten irgendwie Datenschutz und IT-Sicherheit, ne, irgendwie die der Datenschutzdüfte der IT-Sicherheit nicht im im Weg stehen und ja. Also irgendwie etwas komisch. Aber mit anderen Worten, wir,
Wir können uns merken, der Widerstand gegen diese kleine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gegen Cyber-Angriffe ähm,
War erfolgreich beim IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und deswegen müssen sie jetzt einfach den nächsten Anlauf nehmen. Weil wäre ja ein Witz, wenn man so etwas fordert und es dann nicht kommt, ähnlich wie bei der richtigen Vorratsdatenspeicherung eben auch.
Kann's sein, dass er sowas meint, wie ein ähm Frühwarnungssystem, wo sozusagen Angriffe quasi zentral,
gemeldet, erfasst und anderen sozusagen als Frühwarnungsinformation zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz.
Das gibt's ja schon. Also er will verbindungs- und äh Standortdaten irgendwie haben. Mir ist es wirklich nicht ganz klar, was er sagt. Äh was was er hm erwartet, aber er,
Er sagt, das, was äh oder er hat dort das gesagt, was ich gerade äh aus dem Artikel zitiert habe, denn der Artikel zitiert das, was er gesagt hat. Und ich glaube, dass die,
dass die Autoren des Artikels, dass auch äh genau so wiedergegeben haben, weil sie sich selber nichts daraus äh äh selber keinen Reim darauf machen können.
Er sagt sogar, was ich was ich gerade meinte, war IT-Sicherheit und Datenschutz, wer die IT-Sicherheit aufgibt, um den Datenschutz zu gewinnen, der wird am Ende beides verlieren, ja? Bezieht er sich dann mit großen Worten auf äh Benjamin Franklin.
Genau das Gegenteil gesagt hat.
Genau das Gegenteil gesagt hat, ne, wer wer Freiheit aufgibt, um
Sicherheit zu gewinnen, wird am Ende beides verlieren. Da sagt er jetzt, äh wer die IT-Sicherheit aufgibt, um den Datenschutz zu gewinnen. Also der, der Mann ist äh, ist interessant, den sollte man offenbar
auf der Agenda haben.
Nichts äh also und es ist natürlich auch klar, woher der kommt, nur um das kurz noch mit anzubringen. Ähm die das äh es im Innenressort ansässig als IT-Beauftragter der Bundesregierung, ja, also in Ressort.
Weißt du auch, warum der diese Daten haben will.
Dann hat James Klepper.
Gesagt, ja das Internet der Dinge, das kann er sich auch vorstellen, dass das demnächst hier wie so die Spionagehilfe wird. Es gibt ja jetzt Internet der Dinge ist ja jetzt das große neue Ding.
Ja, der Hammer.
Und ähm,
Da wird ja viel drüber diskutiert und dann äh macht man sich eben auch über das Hacking Gedanken, ne? Und dann irgendwie da wird dann viel ähm viel unsicherer Kram gemacht. Also du kannst diese kannst viele dieser dieser Internet-off-Fing-Geschichten,
haben Sicherheitslücken oder einfach keine wirklichen Sicherheitskonzepte.
Und es sind halt kleine Geräte mit wenig mit wenig Bildschirmen, der zeigen kann, dass es einem schlecht geht und äh haben aber natürlich teilweise ganz interessante Sensoren, wie jetzt irgendwie ein Mikrofon, ne, oder ein äh,
Wärmesensor oder auch teilweise verschiedene Aktoren. Und ähm.
IPads in der Gebäudesteuerung.
Allen möglichen Kram, den es da, den es da so gibt, ne? Und ähm in der Regel werden so Internet auf Things Dinge.
Gehackt, um dann weiter in in eine weite in eine andere Richtung zu machen. Ja, also du du heckst, was weiß ich, den Heizungsregler,
um dann von dort aus den den richtigen Rechner anzugreifen, ja? Weil du halt einen schönen, dann hast du halt schon mal einen Fuß im Netz oder so.
Ähm du könntest aber natürlich auch den Heizungsregler, wenn er jetzt einen interessanten Sensor hat, dann kannst du den natürlich irgendwie auch als Wanze
umbauen, ja? Dann heckst du halt den Heizungsregler, weil weil der auf hey Siri oder oder auf irgendwas reagiert und ähm lauscht dann damit den Raum ab und der Klepper sagt, ja ähm.
Und die Dinger werden ja auch gerne so als als äh als Bot-Netzstandorte benutzt, ne? Also finde ich überhaupt schon so eine eine schöne apokalyptische Vision, dass wir Herr Scharen von,
ferngesteuer,
Kühlschränken sozusagen wie so eine Zombiearmee auf unsere Server zuschreiten irgendwie.
Aber es ist interessant, ja, dass dass er das zugibt, dass er sich in diesem Themenfeld bewegen möchte, weil das natürlich für die Leute, ähm die.
Ein Misstrauen gegenüber diesem Geräten haben durchaus eine Wirkung hat, wenn der Klepper sagt, klar
Da können wir Leute mit identifizieren, überwachen, Ortsbestimmungen machen äh und Zielbestimmungen für die Rekrutierung oder den Netzwerkzugang, das eben, ne? Das heißt, ähm,
Von dort aus weiterhecken,
da äh haben wir auf jeden Fall Bock drauf und warnt auch vor der Gefahr dieses Internet auf Things gleichzeitig. Naja, fand ich Note.
Ja, also ich war ja letzte Woche irgendwie in Amsterdam auf so einer Messe, wo es so um Integration ging,
ISI heißt sie. Und da sind halt so ganze Hallen voll mit,
Building Control System und irgendwie und äh,
nur so ein Rotz, weißt du, wo einfach so Millionen solcher Geräte rumstehen und egal
Welche Lösungen du dir anschaust, sowohl die Frickellösung von irgendwo hinterhergelaufenen Firmen, die jetzt so startupmäßig da
Bereich Home-Automation da ihren Senf dazugeben wollen und jetzt unbedingt auch die Wohnzimmerlampe noch irgendwie übern iPad steuern wollen. Noch die industriell aufgestellten, mit Standards unterfütterten Systeme. So ist es einfach
eine notorische Abwesenheit äh der äh der Problematik von Sicherheit,
Zu spüren. So und auch wenn man mit den Leuten redet, ich habe da ein paar längere Gespräche geführt, so.
Wenn man den dem Einzelnen mal so die Dimension aufmacht, was alles irgendwie in ihren Systemen fehlt, so, dann, dann, dann, dann kommen die so ein bisschen ins Schlottern, aber das ist halt irgendwie nix, mit denen die sich groß äh beschäftigen.
So wie ja, äh demnächst bauen wir dann da auch mal Verschlüsselung ein. Bis dahin haben wir dann halt auch schon mal so zwei, dreitausend Gebäude
bezog komplett unauthentifizierten Subsystemen
ausgestattet, die man danach auch einfach nicht mehr so ohne weiteres aus dem Beton gerissen bekommt. Und da steht dann halt dann erstmal rum mit so einer äh typischen Laufdauer von von zehn, zwanzig, dreißig Jahren, nicht upgrade und so weiter, nicht schützbar. Also ich glaube ernsthaft,
ohne jetzt äh,
besonders bekannt zu sein, die apokalypse herbei zu äh beschwören, so. Aber dieses Internet of things mit der aktuellen, miesen, ganz Gesamtsoftwarequalität, die man die so abgeliefert wird auf dem Markt.
Das wird wirklich schlimm. Also ich glaube, das das wird wirklich eine unfassbare Katastrophe. Also das, was wir bisher schon gesehen haben, was,
so gewöhnliche PCs und Laptops, die so im Betrieb sind, was die,
ausgesetzt sind und wie viele davon auch tatsächlich fruchten, ja? Nur da hat man so ein System, was was man noch irgendwie unter den Fingern hat, wo man sieht, dass es vielleicht
langsam ist, komische Dinge tut oder nicht mehr tut oder merkwürdige Sachen angezeigt wird, irgendwas
Dadurch, dass das sozusagen ein persönlicher Computer ist, kann man den ja noch irgendwie so ein bisschen erfühlen, auch wenn da schon äh achtzig Prozent wahrscheinlich der Bedrohung irgendwie nicht gesehen werden. Aber diese ganzen,
Teile, die irgendwo in Gardinensteuerungen und, und, und, und, und Kühlschränken und, und, und, äh, Lichtkontrollern und so weiter rumgammeln,
Das das hat man einfach überhaupt nicht mehr im Griff. Also es ist einfach unkontrollierbar. Das das wird schlimm.
Äh Kinderkrankheiten, da serviert's.
Wird's auch irgendwann äh wird das alles super mit.
Kinderkrankheit sowie Masern.
Verschlüsselung wird das alles in Ordnung.
Ja, ja.
Schlimm. Nee, ja, wenn die, wenn dann die die Leute dir ins Auge schauen und sagen so, nee, nee, äh wir verschlüsseln die PIN auch, die da irgendwie hin und her geht und so, na,
ja und dann ja metrischen Verfahren und so.
Die machen sich einfach keine Gedanken, also sie haben keinen keinen Angreifer, kein Model für ihre komplette Veranstaltung da. Und da werden der Bau natürlich Leute oder
Der Bahnhof
viel schnell auf den Markt geworfen, weil man sich irgendwie denkt, okay krass, oh, ist jetzt irgendwie das neue Ding so, ne, müssen wir jetzt liefern. Und dann müssen wir hier irgendwie fancy blinkend machen und so.
Krypto gibt's dann im nächsten Update. Vielleicht.
Genau oder auch nicht.
PayPal hat mal wieder Leute blockiert. Äh ja diesmal ein ein VPN Anbieter, ähm der den wohlklingenden und vertrauenszweckenden Namen UN hat.
Und ähm es sieht danach aus, dass ähm,
PayPal jetzt gegen so Anblockerdienste vorgeht, also du hast äh was weiß ich, du wohnst in einem Land wo es kein Netflix gibt.
Dann äh wird sich Netflix nicht weigern, dir trotzdem einen Kundenaccount zu geben und dann kannst du so Unblocking-Dienste nutzen, wie äh,
die er dir an andere DNS-Server geben, wo dann direkt ein ganzes VPN ähm
was dann Netflix den Eindruck vermittelt, du wirst in einem bestimmten Land und dann kannst du dieses Angebot eben doch wahrnehmen. Bietet sich zum Beispiel auch
Für deutsche an, wenn man äh das größere US-Angebot schauen möchte oder ich höre Schweden hat äh schöne Netflix-Angebote. Ähm und da kann man dann eben mit mit VPN.
Äh mit VPN-Lösung eben das Geoblocking umgehen. Wir haben ja auch äh wir wissen, äh Julia Reeder will sich gegen dieses Geoblocking wenden. Gunther Oettinger findet aber voll cool. Und ähm,
PayPal sperrt jetzt also VPN-Anbieter, die mit der,
damit werben, dass sie Anblocker sind. Und die Begründung ist, dass äh die die Nutzungsbedingungen von PayPal alle Kunden und Transaktionen,
Alle Kunden und Transaktionen ausschließen, die mit Urheberrechtsverletzungen in Verbindung stehen. Und.
Jetzt klar, wenn man das jetzt böse auslegt, könnten sie damit, könnten sie im Prinzip jeden Anbieter sperren? Weil viele mit,
irgendwo damit in Zusammenhang gebracht werden könnten
Aber sie scheinen sich äh auf die zu konzentrieren, die wirklich äh als Unblocker werben oder was weiß ich eben äh als hier nochmal ordentlich und gib ihm oder so. Könnte sein, aber man weiß es nicht, es ist nur interessant. Ähm,
dass Paypal eben diesen Kunden rausgeworfen hat. Und der Anbieter muss alle Links, Logos und Funktionen PayPals von seiner Seite entfernen.
Mit dir wollen wir nicht. Was ich sehr interessant finde, ne, dass so Zahlungssystem, also PayPal macht das ja nicht zum ersten Mal, die machen das sehr häufig, dass sie sich irgendwo einmischen. Wir hätten auch als Feedback zur letzten Sendung, da haben wir ja darüber gesprochen, wie PayPal ähm
einfriert manchmal, ja, dass dann gesagt wurde, ähm in der Regel, wenn das einmal eingefroren haben, dann behalten sie's einfach, auch ganz gut. Ähm,
So möchtest du deine Zahlungsanbieter haben, dass sie dir erklären, was du zahlen kannst und was nicht. Das ist äh sicherlich noch ein,
Ein weiterer wichtiger Aspekt von diesem Bargeldverbot auch, deswegen habe ich das jetzt nochmal mit aufgenommen.
Genau, das äh finde ich auch gut, dass wir das nochmal kurz äh erwähnen. Ich habe dann im Nachgang auch nochmal so der ein oder andere Interview zu dem Thema angehört. Es gab ja dann auch eine relativ klare Aussage von, wer war das?
Papier. Der ehemalige Verfassungs äh Gerichtspräsiden, der die ich weiß nicht, hatten wir das in der Sendung schon erwähnt, dass er die
geäußert hat, das hatten wir glaube ich nicht, ne? Das hat er nämlich dann äh äh kundgetan und auch aus einem anderen Interview heraus ist mir dann auch nochmal klar geworden,
Dimension gibt, die wir gar nicht erwähnt haben, nämlich die Geldscheine,
also die Euro Banknoten. Nicht übrigens die Münzen,
aber die Banknoten sind es einzige unbegrenzte gesetzliche Zahlungsmittel.
Das bedeutet, wenn du eine Schuld abzutragen hast, so,
Rechnung, keine Ahnung, meinetwegen auch gegenüber dem Finanzamt, et cetera. So, also du bist sozusagen in der Situation, dass du jemandem etwas,
muss, weil du eine eine Verpflichtung hast. Dann darf niemand Euro Geld ablehnen.
Das ist sozusagen das Einzige, garantierte Geld, die einzige Zahlungsweg, den niemand verweigern darf. Wenn du dahin kommst und du hast irgendwie Säcke voll mit Münzen,
Da gibt's eine Deckelung, es gibt einen maximalen Betrag, den ich jetzt grade nicht im Kopf habe, äh bestimmt irgendwie nichts, nicht sehr hoch so, äh weil es nicht zumutbar ist,
Solche Geldmengen in in Münzen entgegenzunehmen. Das gilt nicht für Eurobanknoten und das gilt nur für Eurobanknoten nicht.
Anderen Worten der Zwang, Bankweg zu wählen, ein irgendeiner Form digitalen Weg,
hebt diese unbegrenztheit automatisch auf. Da gibt es dann immer sozusagen Möglichkeiten, dass dass dir diese Bezahlung von etwas äh verhindert wird,
Und das ist natürlich äh dramatisch im Zusammenhang dann mit diesem
fünftausend Euro Bargeld Limit schränkt sozusagen eigentlich deine deine dein das einzige wirklich garantierte gesetzliche Zahlungsmittel sozusagen ein.
Und ähm ja, das ist so ein Aspekt, den ich noch mal kurz äh hier mit einbringen will. Und ich finde das halt immer in dem Moment auch besonders bedenklich, gerade bei bei PayPal, zumal ja PayPal auch eine der,
Wenn nicht sogar der verbreitetste Zahlungsweg im Internet ist, der vor allem ja,
organisatorische, technisch organisatorisches Problem in den USA löst, was wir so in Europa nicht hatten, weil wir hier so einen,
Naja so ein halbwegs brauchbaren elektronischen Zahlungsweg über das äh normale Bankensystem oder SEPA-System hatten, während man.
Genau, wir hatten mal einen. Ja, dann kam.
Nicht schlimmer hatten schon länger, ja wieso, wir, ne, wir haben's ja auch immer noch. Nur in den USA schickt man sich heute noch,
per Post. Das muss man sich mal klarmachen so. Kein Wunder, dass das da so einschlägt und dass man damit äh so reich werden kann, dass man danach anfängt, nur noch Elektroautos und äh Raketen zu bauen, ja?
Also so, nur jetzt ist halt PayPal äh genau in so einer Situation,
wo sie im Prinzip ein Zahlungsverkehr
ermöglichen, auf denen die Leute in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch sich auch verlassen, ne? Wir hatten ja häufig schon diese Fälle mit
Organisationen beziehen viel Spenden und dann wird ihnen einfach mal das Konto gesperrt, weil
irgendein Algorithmus bei Pepel der Meinung ist, das würde jetzt irgendeine Auffälligkeit zeigen et cetera, teilweise mit ewigen äh Geschichten. Wir hatten äh PayPals Rolle, glaube ich, auch im Rahmen der Spenden an äh WikiLeaks hier auch schon mal beleuchtet. Also das ist sozusagen hanebüchen und vor allem ist es auch schwierig
äh im Bezug auf Wessen, Gesetz gilt. Ja, also äh PayPal richtet sich hier im Wesentlichen nach der US-amerikanischen Gesetzgebung. Äh
greift aber dann eben auch durch, wenn Deutsche was in Kuba kaufen.
Und äh das ist ein Problem und äh das verschärft sich in gewisser Hinsicht. Und äh ich denke mal, dass Finanztransaktionen.
Einfach mal ein ganz wichtiges Thema der nächsten Zeit bleiben werden.
Wir würden die ganz gerne weiterhin unser Geld für die Sachen ausgeben können, die wir wollen.
Ja, da muss auch, sagen wir mal, die EU sicherlich einen einen Weg finden oder zumindest die Eurozone oder auf welcher Ebene man das jetzt auch am besten äh abbildet, da bin ich kein Experte.
Äh das wäre im Prinzip äh auch andere Garantien für elektronische Zahlungswege bekommen. Die ist so derzeit einfach schlicht nicht gibt,
Kein Wunder, dass hier so viele auf Bitcoin stürzen, weil's da eben genau diese Verhinderung nicht gibt.
Also niemand kann dich davon abhalten, der derzeit mit Bitcoin was zu bezahlen. So und das ist halt sonst nur beim bei Geldschaden gegeben so.
Wie geht's weiter?
Es geht weiter mit dem mit dem Thema, auf das wir letzte Woche schon so äh rausgeblickt haben, aber dann am Ende es eigentlich schon vorweggenommen haben. Julio A Sanchez, ja.
Ah. Ja. Hey, hey, ja.
Denn die eine UN Arbeitsgruppe zum Thema willkürliche Inhaftierung bescheinigt ihm eine willkürliche Inhaftierung. Und zwar sagen sie, das ist schon passiert.
Am siebten zwölften zweitausendzehn, als er nämlich zehn Tage in Isolationshaft in war.
Und Little frism.
Das sei die erste Verletzung seiner äh also äh das sei die erste Haft gewesen, dass er dann unter Hausarrest mit äh mit Fußfessel stand ebenfalls
dass er jetzt in der Botschaft sitzen muss auch. Dieses zu diesem Urteil kommen sie und schreiben was wir,
Dabei nicht betrachtet haben, ist die schwedische Voruntersuchung zur Belästigung und Vergewaltigung und der europäische Haftbefehl, die ihm,
anlasten.
Ja? Jetzt hat die diese UN-Arbeitsgruppe, dieses dieses Urteil gefällt und da eben das angekreidet. Ähm das hat aber keinerlei bindende Wirkung. Es verpflichtet, aber zur Stellungnahme.
Also die Großbritannien muss jetzt darauf antworten,
auf das, was ihn, was der Krone da vorgehalten wird in diesem Bericht.
Also verpflichtend im Rahmen der Mitgliedschaft äh der Länder der UN. Mhm.
Gut, jetzt können die hier über den Assanches noch aus der UN austreten. Das halte ich für unwahrscheinlich. Ich denke, sie werden antworten. Sie haben auch schon sich ein paar Worte zurechtgelegt. Ähm der britische Außenminister Hemmend meinte nämlich, ja
Gutachten ist juristisch, fehlerhaft und lächerlich.
Das ist bestimmt die Art von Statement, die sie sich erwünscht haben.
Äh die äh schwedische Chefanklägerin äh Marianne Nü ähm sagte ja schön, was die UN da macht, was ändert an meinen Beurteilungen nichts,
Gut, sie hat den, sie ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt dafür verantwortlich, was dem äh.
Ob und wie der Julian da in in Großbritannien behandelt wird.
Und die schwedische Außenministerin sagte, auf diesen Satz habe ich gewartet, das ist meine Assange steht es jederzeit frei, die Botschaft zu verlassen,
Deshalb ist er durch keine Handlung der schwedischen Behörden in seiner Freiheit eingeschränkt. Die Regierung bestreitet deshalb die Ansicht der UN-Arbeitsgruppe.
Ja wo steht denn, dass er dass er nicht aus dem Haus rausgehen kann? Das kann er aus dem Haus raus.
Niemand hat den, so ist dann Wächter, ist dann Wärter, der die so, nein, der kann da jederzeit raus, der ist doch nicht inhaftiert, inhaftiert.
Danach dann halt.
Da hat sie dann halt schon rechts so das also das Argument ist schon klar, weißt du? Du kannst ja nicht irgendwie also überspitzt, du kannst ja nicht,
Quasi fliehen und dich irgendwie,
In in einen Ort flüchten, wo die äh wo die Polizei nicht hinkommt, denen halt blöd irgendwie so eine sechzig Quadratmeterbude wählen und dann sagen die inhaftieren mich hier. Nee, tun sie nicht
Wenn du rauskommst, dann inhaftieren sie dich.
Riesenunterschied, ja.
Ja. Aber ähm das blickt ja mal, wirft ja mal wieder,
den Blick dorthin. Warum sitzt er da eigentlich immer noch, ja? Es gab nämlich dann jetzt vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten dann einen Antrag der schwedischen Anklage, den Holio in der Botschaft,
Zudem Vergewaltigungsvorwurf zu befragen,
Die hatte dann aber Ecuador äh im Januar aus formalen Gründen abgelehnt. Also formale Gründe, weiß ich nicht, irgendwas war damit halt nicht in Ordnung,
Die äh Marianne Nü schreibt jetzt gerade einen neuen Antrag.
Und da ging's dann auch, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, ging's dann um die Debatte, wer ob die jetzt reinkommen und wie die denn dann befragen oder nicht. Und ähm,
Zwischenzeit äh schickt die die Marianne Nü eben den Behörden Ecuadors fragen. Ähm,
deren Grundlage equarianische Beamte ähm Assange befragen wollten. Ähm,
irgendeine komische Einigung, dass also jetzt.
Die equarianische Botschaft sagt, ja, die Fragen können wir dem auch stellen. Schickt die mal rüber. Also da ist irgendwie so ein komisches äh komisches hin und her.
Es ist aber nach wie vor unklar, wann jetzt diese Befragung stattfinden könnte
und wie das da jetzt genau läuft, also die die zanken sich dann nach wie vor. Aber inzwischen ja sitzt der, glaube ich, seit drei Jahren in dieser Botschaft, ne?
Wie die Zeit vergeht, das wird er allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht so sehen.
Vor drei Jahren in einem Zimmer. Also ich meine, das ist halt wie Haft.
Ja, natürlich, also wir lachen da jetzt so gemeint. Ja, das ist wie Haft. Natürlich ist das wie Haft. Ähm am Ende stehen wir ja.
Wieder bei der Debatte der Sorge um eine Auslieferung. Er sagt ja nicht.
Ich stelle mich nicht diesen Vorwürfen, die die ähm schwedische Anklägerin äh gegen mich erhebt,
Ganz im Gegenteil, den möchte ich mich sehr gerne stellen, aber wenn ich Fuß nach Schweden setze oder wenn diese Befragung dann vorbei ist und die Schweden äh die schwedischen Behörden meiner habhaft sind, dann rechne ich damit, dass ein Auslieferungsgesuch der USA kommt.
Wegen des größeren Verbrechens und der deshalb möchte ich äh nicht dahin. Ähm.
Es gibt von vielen Vertreten die Ansicht, dass eine Auslieferung aus den aus den Vereinigten Königreich sehr viel wahrscheinlicher wäre als eine aus Schweden.
Das vermag ich aber nicht zu beurteilen.
Das vermag ich auch nicht zu beurteilen. Ich meine mich daran zu erinnern, dass es äh da ein Gesetz gibt, ähm was,
die Auslieferung von Mitgliedern des Common Worlds.
Äh sozusagen nicht erlaubt. Da bewege ich mich aber auf diesem Ort, den man als dünnes Eis äh,
weil meine Erinnerung nicht da etwas trügt, aber das war, sagen wir mal so ein bisschen meine meine Kenntnis und das mag auch dazu beigetragen haben, dass er überhaupt,
nach England gegangen ist.
Schweden in dem Moment die größere Gefahr darstellt, weil es eben dann diese Regelung nicht gibt so. Äh man möge mich korrigieren, wer da mehr äh Einblicke hat. Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen aus meiner Erinnerung heraus, da kann ich auch falsch liegen. Ähm.
Ja. Es ist äh ja, wann der Mann sitzt da in dieser Botschaft, ne.
Auf kleiner Flamme und macht Internetvideos.
Ja und teilweise auch relativ krude Verlautbarungen irgendwie in letzter Zeit aus dem Hause Wiki Leaks, aber weiß ich nicht, wenn man da irgendwie.
Das ist so der geistigen Sanität auch nicht unbedingt zuträglich.
Ja gut, ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre der einzige Mensch, den unsere Gesellschaften einsperren, ne, also wir machen das regelmäßig.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall geht's so recht nicht voran. Hm vor allem macht,
alles nicht so den Eindruck, als ob irgendjemand ein großes Interesse daran hätte, diesen Status quo zu ändern, also in gewisser Hinsicht sind die auch ganz zufrieden äh,
alle Beteiligten recht zufrieden wohl mit dieser Situation, weil.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du den Assange so zufrieden.
Ja nee, außer ihm natürlich, aber das äh das ist jetzt nicht so, ich meine, ich könnte mir ja auch vorstellen, dass man so als,
britische Regierung oder sagen wir mal als Regierung eines Landes in der Nähe von Europa äh sein Interesse daran hätte so einen Fall,
Einfach mal ausm Land rauszukriegen. Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, in Deutschland,
würde irgendjemand irgendeine Botschaft geflohen sein und den ganzen Tag YouTube-Videos von dort produzieren und irgendwie dagegen, also das wäre doch ein unhaltbarer Zustand.
Weiß der Geier, was noch kommt, aber so heute, ja, würde, würde ich das einfach äh das wäre einfach ein Fall.
Das könnte bei uns nicht passieren.
Also habe ich Schwierigkeiten mir das vorzustellen, dass, dass, dass das medial irgendwie durchzufechten wäre. Und äh das ist halt in äh Britannien offenbar nicht so, ne.
Das hat viel mit dem komischen Selbstverständnis dieses Landes äh zu tun und ähm wir haben, glaube ich, keine,
keine Ahnung wie viel,
klein, klein, Politik da auf den kürzesten Dienstwegen hier 'ne Rolle spielt aber so mit Recht und Gesetz scheint mir das alles nicht mehr so richtig viel zu tun zu haben.
Geschweige denn mit hohem humanitären Grundsätzen.
Und jetzt sind wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt und blicken auf die Nachrichten, die der Woche.
Und vor zwanzig Jahren.
Vor zwanzig Jahren, denn äh vor zwanzig Jahren hat John Perry Balu die Unabhängigkeit des Cyberspace erklärt.
Ja, wer ist schon.
Von.
Ja also ist ein ein Mensch mit vielen äh Facetten.
Er ist halt als äh ja Textschreiber, der Bandgrade unter anderem auch äh bekannt geworden und äh mag auch noch so ein paar andere ähm,
andere Wege eingeschlagen haben in äh in seinem Leben, über die ich keine weitere Kenntnis habe, mich auch nicht groß drüber auslassen möchte. Tatsache ist, dass er eben einer der Gründer der IFF
ist,
wir ja hier schon oft erwähnt haben und vor zwanzig Jahren ist es so ein bisschen mit ihm durchgegangen, da hat er sich irgendwie mal hingesetzt in so einem äh Moment, der geistigen,
Intensität und äh hat eine,
geschrieben, so eine Art, ja, wir äh wir, die wir die Digitalen sind
Wir die Bewohner des Cyberspace, also damit sozusagen auch diese klare Trennung
äh des des wir gegen sie, wir das Neue, ihr das Alte, wir, das, das, das äh
sagen wir mal, international vernetzte, globale, moderne Gedankengut, Versus, äh die etablierten Strukturen in Form von Industrie und Government ähm
die hinter uns liegen und so ein bisschen zur Kenntnis gegeben, dass das, dass man nichts mit anderen zu tun haben möchte.
Beginnt Regierungen der industriellen Welt. Ihr Müdenriesen aus Fleisch und Stahl. Ich komme aus dem Cyber Space, dem neuen Zuhause des Geistes.
Als Vertreter der Zukunft bitte ich euch, aus der Vergangenheit,
in Ruhe zu lassen. Ihr seid nicht willkommen unter uns. Ihr habt keine Souveränität, wo wir uns versammeln,
Ich denke, die Sendung hat schon gezeigt, was die Regierungen der industriellen Welt äh so tagein tagaus mit unserem Cyber-Space machen, oder?
Vor allem wie die das so sehen. Also,
Das ist eine schöne Sicht der Dinge, also es sind zwei zwei Sachen, die mir hier sozusagen eigentlich gleichzeitig so ins in den Kopf kommen. Erstens, wie du schon richtig andeutest,
der Wunsch, der sich hier eigentlich zwischen den Zeilen ausdrückt, dass man woanders ist und da so ein bisschen so ein, so ein, so ein,
den Staat auf der Insel so wir sind außerhalb eurer Juristik, wir sind außerhalb eurer äh traditionellen Pfade und wir machen das jetzt hier einfach mal anders und bleibt mal weg,
hat sich nicht erfüllt. Ja, das ist halt einfach,
worden. Man hat halt einfach äh den freien Geist dort nicht machen lassen, beziehungsweise dieses Entstehen des freien Geistes, was definitiv gegeben hat, was auch definitiv vor zwanzig Jahren,
ein großes Thema war und ich würde auch sagen, gerade für so eine Szene wie unsere auch so einen gewissen so ein bisschen Selbstverständnis war.
Dass das dann im Prinzip als Bedrohung auch erkannt wurde.
Ja, also dieses Abgrenzen mit, was ja lange Zeit sehr gut funktioniert hat, weil einfach das Unwissen auf der anderen Seite so groß war, erstmal über die pure Existenz dieses Raums, dann über die Ausprägung, die Regeln, die Gesetze, die Fähigkeiten auch,
ähm das ist jetzt vorbei. Das Netz ist klar im Fokus,
und gerade dieser Freigeist wird eben als Bedrohung angesehen und das zeigt sich halt in dieser ganzen
Überwachungsgeschichte, das zeigt sich eben mit den ganzen repressiven Maßnahmen, wie sie in sehr, sehr, sehr vielen Ländern nahezu allen eigentlich äh eingeleitet worden sind,
teilweise hinter den Kulissen,
mit dem Versuch ist so unauffällig wie möglich zu machen, wie in den USA oder eben auch einfach oder auch nur im geringsten einen Zweifel äh zu lassen, wie man da vorgeht, äh ob das dann äh weiß ich,
Iran, die arabischen Staaten äh,
natürlich Saudi-Arabien et cetera, also Türkei auch, ne, also mit ihren offenen Zensurmaßnahmen, mit ihren offenen äh Verboten
Pakistan, teilweise eben über die Religion, teilweise einfach über die Politik oder teilweise einfach über dieses, wir machen das jetzt einfach und ihr könnt da gar nichts gegen machen, so Russland-Style
ja, wo also gar nicht mehr groß äh versucht wird, das überhaupt noch.
Irgendeinen irgendein Thema zu stellen, sondern das wird dann halt einfach so getan,
Ja und jetzt äh finde ich ist der Cyber Space liegt ziemlich röchelnd in der Ecke äh durchlöchert,
blutend und äh weiß grad gar nicht so richtig, welche Pillen er noch einschmeißen soll, um irgendwie diesen Zustand äh zu verlassen.
Von daher hat es nicht äh so richtig funktioniert. War ich jetzt schon bei dem zweiten Punkt,
Also man hat uns nicht gelassen und es ist alles unter ähm Feuer, genau. Mein zweiter Punkt, den ich so ein bisschen da noch rauslese, mit diesem Cyber Space.
Dieses Wunschdenken, das das der Cyberspace was anderes ist als das richtige Leben.
Ich glaube, den muss man auch so ein bisschen beerdigen. In gewisser Hinsicht ist es auch viel produktiver. Das haben die Debatten auch gezeigt,
In dem Moment, ist es produktiver, das eher andersrum zu sehen, dass man einfach sagt, nein, auch die digitale Welt ist die normale Welt. Äh.
Bedrohungsszenarien im Netz, ja, eine Bedrohung im Netz ist nicht schwächer,
eine Bedrohung im realen Leben, nur weil sie nicht mit unmittelbaren physikalischen Kontakt zu tun hat
und äh an vielen Stellen zeigt sich halt einfach, dass dass sich in diesem Netz einfach
guten wie im Schlechten einfach die Realität abbildet und dass sie letzten Endes auch nichts anderes ist als die Realität,
oder anders ausgedrückt, eigentlich gibt's diesen Suver Space eigentlich gar nicht.
Ja, die Frage, also was ich ganz die Frage, die ich mir stelle, was war,
oder was ist der Cyber-Space? Ja, also er er sagt, ähm.
Der Cyberspace besteht aus Transaktionen, Beziehungen und dem Gedanken selbst, äh wie eine stehende Welle in einem Netz aus unserer Kommunikation,
äh unseres unsere ist eine Welt, die sowohl überall als auch nirgends ist, aber auf jeden Fall nicht da, wo die Körper leben. Ähm.
Das ist natürlich relativ breit definiert, ne? Also ich meine wo hat man neunzehnhundertsechsundneunzig diesen Cyber Space erlebt, ja, wahrscheinlich irgendwie im IRC, ja? Oder.
Mailboxsystem in ja in den ersten Kommunikationskreisen, im.
Wo es halt wirklich also wo's relativ einfache Formen gab, Foren gab, ja, da ging es um mehr oder weniger textbasierte Kommunikation, da konntest du vielleicht auch mal ja, da,
Da waren jetzt noch da gab es noch keine großen Dienstleistungen wie äh Videostreaming oder äh oder soziale Netzwerke, die diese die das, was Cyber-Space ist.
Im Prinzip kommerzialisieren wollen, ne? Also es, das war wahrscheinlich auch für ihn damals,
nicht nicht abzusehen oder auch unvorstellbar, dass die Menschen.
Den Cyberspace in die Hände,
von Unternehmen legen würden, statt auf Basis von freier Software eben den den Austausch irgendwie zu zu pflegen und das glaube ich ist der, der entscheidende Unterschied, es ist gar nichts oder das, was er,
Die Regierungen sind nicht in diese Cyber-Face Dingen reingegangen, was er damals hatte,
Dieses dem Forum oder was auch immer da seine Kommunikationswege waren, wo er jetzt die die weltweit äh das weltweit umspannende Netzwerk der Gedanken äh gesehen hat.
Aber in dieses Datennetz sind die Unternehmen gekommen und mit den Unternehmen äh auch die Regulierungen und die die Gesetze, die Staaten äh,
um sie herum,
begeben. Das heißt, der Cyber-Space ist auch einfach nicht mehr der, der mal war und das, was heute am nächsten Ende des, das, was dem Cyberspace am nächsten käme, wäre halt Facebook.
Ja vor allem ich meine die die eigen sich am Anfang hat es natürlich vor allem,
viele äh kreative Denker,
Leute, die sich gerne und also auf so einer höheren Ebene austauschen, Ideen austauschen, machen Wissenschaftler äh ja, also Leute, denen sagen wir mal, auch so der der.
Austausch als solcher einfach sehr naheliegt. Die haben sich da getummelt. Natürlich hat das Netz dadurch damals auch eine
enormen Reiz gehabt, weil du kamst halt einfach in so ein ja in so einen Raum, in so ein in den Cyberraum, ja
Es war äh Full of Stars. So, es waren einfach sozusagen voll mit interessanten Menschen, die über interessante Dinge reden, die auch einen.
Halbwegs ähm brauchbaren Umgang miteinander pflegten in der Regel. So und das war dann halt irgendwann
Naja es wurde schon auch mal ordentlich rumgepumpt und und und rumgeflämt, aber es war, sagen wir mal, also gerade bis sechsundneunzig, da war die Welt noch äh ziemlich in Ordnung,
Ähm,
besondere in den mit Facebook vergleichbaren Communitys, ne, wie zum Beispiel, was ich äh erwähnt habe, was halt so ein so ein so ein Ort ist, in dem sich gerade die
ähm die frühen Denker äh und Netzphilosophen äh des Silicon Valley halt rumgetrieben haben und da wirklich halt sozusagen am äh an, an, an Zukunftskonzept
und, und, und idealen äh rumgefeilt haben und sicherlich gut gemeint haben und äh sicherlich auch auf tolle Ideen gekommen sind.
Problem ist halt, wenn du dann halt erstmal so, dass dass das globale Großproletariat äh auch noch mit im Boot hast, dann dann werden die Diskussionen halt ein bisschen ruppiger.
Das war halt heute,
Ich weiß nicht, ob deshalb auch dieses Wort dann halt einfach jetzt grade durch die Debatte in den letzten Jahren und wir haben's ja jetzt auch wieder schon paar Mal gehabt, ne. Wenn der Cyber kommt, so dann dann rollen wir ja dann auch schon ein bisschen mit den Augen.
Schwierig. Ähm ich glaube, glaube auch fest an einen,
Moment des Revivals, also wir werden sicherlich so eine so eine intellektuelle,
Revolutionen,
nochmal erleben. Das ist etwas, was was nochmal kommt. Nur jetzt ist grad schwierig,
Jetzt jetzt prallt alles jetzt, wir wir sind einfach in in so einer Art Urknall gelandet, der Hyperinflation, dieses digitalen Raums,
alle stürzen sich auf einmal drauf, Business, Die Welt, Zahlen
Indien, wir hatten's gerade, Milliarden neue User. Äh es ist es ist einfach eine eine unglaubliche Ausdehnung und eine unglaubliche Erhitzung und und wie als das Universum so in dieser Urknallinflations Phase war, äh
kein Licht, ja? Es war alles irgendwie eine eine un.
Eine einzige Gravitationswelle.
Eine Suppe, einfach eine eine Gravitations äh äh Suppe, ja, die die Wellen ausstößt, die irgendwie auch viel, eine ganze Menge Energie freisetzt, aber keinerlei Klarheit äh bietet. So und jetzt muss man irgendwie erstmal ein bisschen abwarten, bis sich das wieder abkühlt
bis die Leute erstmal anfangen äh auch mal wieder Informationen zu äh zu richtig zu empfangen und nicht nur in so einem permanenten Battle mit Links und Rechts zu sein,
und dann äh können wir, glaube ich, nochmal klar gucken. So, ne? Aber damals äh als wir halt als alles sich sozusagen noch in so einem nukleos äh
abspielte und der einzige Beschluss, der da war, war, oah, lass uns mal jetzt mal richtig ausdehnen, so, das ist bestimmt geil.
Ja und dann wird's irgendwie wird's heiß so, ne?
Na ja, die Deklaration of Cyberspace, das ist im Prinzip so ein bisschen so eine Gravitationswelle, ja, so ein Moment, wo wo einfach mal einer auf den Tisch gehauen hat und gesagt hat, wir sind jetzt hier aber mal total unabhängig und ihr kackt uns alle an und wir wollen mit euch nichts zu tun haben
zwanzig Jahre später empfangen wir irgendwie diese kleine Schockwelle und naja, ist ziemlich schwach.
Der Text hat aber natürlich auch nochmal eine andere Bedeutung für ein Selbstverständnis,
ja, der wurde immer wieder auch von diesen ganzen enormen äh Geschichten oder so aufgegriffen, ja?
Ähm immer wieder so dieses äh wird sich immer wieder drauf bezogen als konstituierendes Element für irgendwelche Protest äh Geschichten
ähm und das ist schon ein ganz guter Text, ein bisschen lang für die heutige Zeit, heute würde man den kürzer machen,
Auch das äh er hatte ja einen Grund, den zu schreiben, nämlich den damaligen Telekommunikations Reform-Act, der in den äh in den USA äh als Gesetz äh verabschiedet wurde, auf den er da auch Bezug nimmt.
Aber er hat äh er ist ein guter Textschreiber und hat.
Trifft da nach wie vor, finde ich, eine Lebenshaltung und eine Einstellung.
Die wir teilen.
Müsste man vielleicht jetzt nochmal so als Buzzfeed Compliant listical äh machen,
Gründe, warum eine Regierung sich besser raushalten sollten. Die Leute wird dich überraschen.
Die Witze ziehen da auch nicht mehr lange, ne? Also gut, dass man die da untergebracht haben.
So, jetzt haben wir genug äh untergebracht, oder?
Ja. Äh könnte also ihr da draußen, die ihr das jetzt vielleicht hört, äh wenn ihr das noch nicht gelesen habt, lest das mal durch.
Wir haben ein sehr schönes Video verlinkt.
Genau, wo er das ist, liest er da einfach den Text vor, oder? Ja, genau. Oder hört euch das an, das ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen kompatibler so mit der heutigen Zeit, in der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, je nachdem. Wer,
Medium. Ist schon jemand, der ähm,
Seine Verdienste hat, es gab ja auch mal, kann man auch nochmal kurz erwähnen, äh war ja auch mal auf dem Kongress, auf dem dreiundzwanzig C drei, hat da ähm die Knote gehalten,
hat den Ton nicht so ganz getroffen, weil ihm glaube ich in dem Moment auch die,
Dimension der der deutschen Hackerkultur,
nicht so ganz klar war und er doch aus einer sehr amerikanischen Perspektive ähm dazu den Leuten gesprochen hat. Das gab dann auch interessante Debatten im äh Nachgang,
Wir verkünden das ja auch nochmal kurz verlinken. Ähm aber.
Scheint ja so die richtige Rede vor dem falschen Publikum.
Ja, so genau, aber das war ja auch dreiundzwanzigster, war ja auch so ein bisschen so der Beginn, wo wir im Kongress auch diesen Outreach nach,
USA überhaupt erst so richtig äh gestartet haben und von daher interessante äh interessanter Moment in der in der Zeitwertung.
Ja, auch so eine kleine Gravitationswelle.
Und damit äh entlassen wir euch diese Woche. Ne?
Tschau, tschau. Ja, wir gehen jetzt weg.
Macht's gut und äh bleibt autonom.
Damit zurück in den Cyberspace.